Good morning John!
So a little while ago, I went on Google, and
I was going to ask the question, "What is
the difference between something and something?".
But I didn't get that far because I noticed
how interesting all the questions other people
were asking were.
So having forgotten completely what I was
going to ask Google, instead, today I'm just
going to answer all of the questions other
people were asking for every letter of the
alphabet.
Starting with: A.
Crows and ravens are two completely different
species.
If there's a bunch of them and they're acting
and sounding pretty annoying, those are crows.
If there's one or two of them, and you think,
"Is that a cat, because it's huge," that's
a raven.
Baking soda is the chemical sodium bicarbonate.
It produces carbon dioxide when mixed with
an acid, and that carbon dioxide fluffs up
baked goods.
Baking powder is baking soda with the acid
already mixed in, so all you have to do is
add water.
In the US, a college is a school that teaches
only the years directly after secondary education.
A university has some graduate school components.
To make things extra confusing, both colleges
and universities can contain other colleges.
Dinner vs. supper is a really interesting
linguistic thing that happened.
Apparently, supper means a different thing
to EVERYONE.
English people and things are from England,
which is a country inside the country of the
United Kingdom.
British people and things technically are
anything from the United Kingdom, so Northern
Irish people, Welsh people, Scottish people:
all British - though they probably don't want
to be called that.
Hair and fur are, scientifically, the exact
same thing.
Hulu Plus costs more, and you can watch it
on your TV or your mobile device.
There's also very slightly more content on
Hulu Plus.
The 5C is the, kind of, value edition of the
iPhone.
The camera and the processor and the design
are all a little bit less fancy.
Jelly is jellied juice and jam is jellied
fruit pulp, so jam is a little bit softer.
As with anything in linguistics, this is surprisingly
complicated, but both kun and san are Japanese
honorific suffixes.
They're added to the end of names to show
respect.
San is used between equals, while kun is used
in reference to someone junior to you, generally
a male person.
LCD is the kind of display technology, LED
is the kind of back-lighting the TV has.
They have nothing to do with each other, and
these days, most TVs are LCD displays back-lit
by LED.
I mean, biologically, there's very little
difference between you and me.
Humans are all very, very similar to each
other.
I have no idea what NAS and SAN are.
I looked it up, and it's something to do with
IT infrastructure, and sorry, out of my depth
there.
Subjective statements are based in opinion;
objective statements are based in fact.
This first one makes no sense, so I'm gonna
skip it.
Prisons are where you go when you've been
convicted of a crime and sentenced to serve
time.
Jails are where you go when you've just been
detained or have been arrested and are awaiting
trial.
You can also end up in a jail if you've been
convicted but your sentence isn't very long.
Both full and quick formats will wipe all
the data off your hard drive, but only the
full format will rebuild the file structures
that the drive itself uses to store the files
and scan for bad sectors on the drive.
Both Rangers and Green Berets are special
operations forces in the Army.
Any recruit can apply to be a Ranger, but
only soldiers who have been in the army for
at least three years can apply to be a Green
Beret.
Green Berets must also speak at least two
languages.
The duties performed by both groups, though,
are similar.
Scotch is a type of whiskey.
It's Scotch, meaning that it's made in Scotland.
"Too" either means "excessively" or "also."
"To" is just for all the other times, unless
you mean "two."
As far as I can tell, Uber and Lyft are pretty
much the same thing.
They're both new-fangled ways to get taxis,
and people seem surprisingly excited about
both considering that taxis will be mostly
driven by robots in ten years.
Green cards give you the right to permanently
live and work in the US, while visas only
temporarily give you that right.
Green and white asparagus are the same plant,
but white asparagus has dirt piled on top
of it while it's growing, so that it's never
exposed to light.
Under all that dirt, it doesn't produce chlorophyll,
and it doesn't need the structures necessary
to stand up on its own, so it's milder in
flavor and softer in texture.
x64 is the 64-bit CPU architecture for Windows
7 that works on newer machines, while x86
is the older 32-bit design.
Green and yellow zucchini are different colors.
And finally,
A zucchini is a squash!
John, I hope this video was educational for
you and for everybody else, and I'll see you
on Tuesday.
I made this script publicly available before
I made this video, as part of the Nerdfighter
Online Video Workshop, so people have already
uploaded their versions of this video on their
channels before I did, which is weird.
So far, the NOVW is, just, very cool.
Thanks to everyone who's been doing performances
and edits and script-writing, and especially
to people who have been constructively critiquing
those performances and edits and scripts.
If you'd like to learn more about the NOVW,
there's a link in the description.